[Music]  [Applause]  here's a wonderful Christmas gifts for  anyone who smokes because it says Merry  Christmas and happy smoking  here's a wonderful new idea for  Christmas fun now you can turn your home  into a window wonderland with a magic of  glass wax and a set of these easy to use  cut out stencils for glass wax give her  an aristocrat infrared cooker for  Christmas a duster great cooks  everything so much faster and it's so  easy to prepare  just heat dr. pepper or diet dr. pepper  till it's deep then pour over a thin  slice of lemon and  piping hot how do you like this Timex  Christmas tree oh especially a beautiful  famous this way well on this tree you  will find a Timex watch for everyone in  the whole world so much that take the  lickin and keeps on tickin  [Music]  she will treasure Gillette there's a  delet razor priced for every budget  Christmas gift you can give your teenage  son husband father or any man will steal  heart  [Music]